residency do you rep at home okay you
know we're repping LV over here on Las
Vegas now and that's what local Hat
Company residency is all about so Angelo
and Andrew are here to gear us up for
football season and Beyond because these
have to be worn all year round all the
time especially ahead of our Raiders
home opener this Sunday welcome guys
thanks for having me thanks JC we
appreciate it I I these are some of my
favorite hats shout out to Zach another
one of the owners right he's actually
he's actually out of photo shoot right
now with Darren Waller of the Raiders
yes he is yeah you're going to see some
great content coming from it we love it
so let's get let's get to it who are you
guys where are you guys from so we're
from Vegas most our lives right middle
school high school college just always
having a way to represent our city we
never really had that growing up right
the Raiders and golden knights that came
so much later absolutely but then
obviously we wanted to have a way to
represent our residency opposed to
representing a corporation or a team and
just really giving back to that and just
associating with you know our purpose
and what the residency is and that's
what the company is all about so you
guys make hats not just for
to say that another five markets are
releasing before the end of the year
they'll sneak peek Miami is coming we
got Jacksonville we got some good things
coming okay okay now let's talk about
the hat so let's separates you guys from
you know everybody else yeah so it's won
our brand Mission and our vision right
but with this collaboration it was
really giving back to the community so
with the Darren Waller foundation and
obviously Darren Waller's blessing we
released the wall or one the wall or two
and the wall or three oh shoot we're
actually singing some photos of your
guys I know there he is
yeah that really spoke to his journey
his legacy past and present and what his
future really does look like wow okay so
what else um you know we have these two
these are some of your Classics right
yeah so really with the Waller 50 of the
proceeds are going to the Darren Waller
Foundation only 83 of them are being
made because
but these other styles and the styles
that you see behind we have the strip as
an homage obviously we don't have the
string I have like five of those I love
the straps and then we got the trout and
then we have some other styles also
behind us oh it's to represent inside
back to the city so cool and also you
guys at home can customize your hats as
well with you guys so tell everybody how
they can rep too yeah so head to
residency.com you see it behind us or
check out all of our social handles at
residency on Instagram Facebook Twitter
check us out thank you Angelo Andrew
refio residency thank you appreciate it
thank you we'll be right back